وينضم الان الينا من غلاف غزه مراسلنا
الياس كرام الياس لا ادري اذا كانت لديك
تفاصيل بشان ما كنا اوردناه عن دوي صفارات
الانذار في بلدات الجولان السوري المحتل
او اي معلومه جديده من الجانب الاسرائيلي
تريد ان تزودنا
بها الفعل صافرات الانذار دوت في الجولان
السوري المحتل تحديدا في المناطق الشماليه
في عين ومجدل شمس والعديد من المستوطنات
الاسرائيليه القريبه من هاتين البلدتين
السوريتين
والبلاغ الاولي الذي جاء من الجبهه
الداخليه للجيش الاسرائيلي يتحدث عن
الاشتباه بمسيره معاديه كما يبدو اخترقت
الاجواء من تلك المنطقه لا يعرف بعد فيما
اذا كان الاختراق قد تم من الاجواء
اللبنانيه ام من الاجواء السوريه لكن هذا
الموضوع قيد البحث هذا ياتي بعد اقل من
ساعه تقريبا او ساعه تقريبا من اعتراض
مسيره فوق مدينه عكا او قرب خليج حيفا في
المناطق الشماليه كانت اخترقت الاجواء
بحسب بيان الجيش الاسرائيلي من الاراضي
اللبنانيه او من الاجواء اللبنانيه وواضح
بان الاوضاع على الحدود الاسرائيليه
اللبنانيه تسخن وهي مرتبطه بدون ادنى شك
ليلى بما يحدث هنا ايضا في قطاع غزه حيث
ان الجيش الاسرائيلي ما زال يرا وح مكانه
في العمليات البريه دون ان يحقق صوره
صار واضحه وواحده حسب ما يقول كثير من
الخبراء العسكريون والضباط والقيادات
الامنيه السابقه في الجيش الاسرائيلي
الذين يتحدثون عن انجازات تكتيكيه تراكميه
للجيش الاسرائيلي دون ان يحرز ولو انجازا
استراتيجيا واحدا يمكنه ان يقدمه على انه
انجاز للمجتمع الاسرائيلي وهذا ايضا ما
تشير اليه بيانات الجيش الاسرائيلي نفسها
التي يبدو وكانها
بمثابه قص ولصق للبيانات السابقه في
الايام الماضيه مع تغيير ارقام الوحدات
والالو العامله وتغيير التواريخ بمعنى لا
شيء يذكر حقيقه على ارض الواقع سوى ان
القوات الاسرائيليه تقول بانها تواصل
عملياتها العسكريه وتتعمق في اكثر من موقع
وفي اكثر من مكان في داخل قطاع غزه
المناطق الشماليه لمدينه غزه كانت شهدت
هذا الصباح ليلى قصفا مدفعيا عنيفا خفت
حدته حقيقه في الساعات الاخيره لكن واضح
بانه كان يستهدف الاحياء الشماليه لمدينه
غزه تحديدا حيي التفاح والدرج حيث يقول
الجيش الاسرائيلي بانه عمق من عملياته
العسكريه هناك في المناطق الجنوبيه لمدينه
غزه في منطقه جحر الديك هذه المنطقه كانت
تعرضت لغار جويه عنيفه ظهر هذا اليوم
وتبعها ايضا قصف مدفعي متقطع في اكثر من
مكان هناك بالاضافه الى الاطراف الشماليه
ل مخيمي البريج وانصراف حيث قال الجيش
الاسرائيلي انه يعمل هناك في الايام
الثلاثه الماضيه في محاوله لتعميق عمليته
العسكريه وبطبيعه الحال التركيز من جانب
الجيش الاسرائيلي هو على المنطقه الجنوبيه
وتحديدا مدينه خن اشكرك جدا الياس كرام من
غلاف غزه
k